org and click on book club to enter the
chat room
edwin black is next on book tv
he argues that tax-exempt or otherwise
publicly subsidized organizations like
the ford foundation george soros open
society foundations and the new israel
fund are working to block peace and
reconciliation between jews and
palestinians in israel
this is about an hour 20 minutes
so i'm edwin black
and this is my uh second appearance at
congress in
the last two years on the subject of
human rights
i will begin this
briefing in the same way that i began my
last briefing
for congress for representative trent
franks
on the subject of eugenics
in the united states then that is that i
come here not as a
republican or a democrat or a liberal or
a conservative but as a historian and
investigative reporter who is concerned
primarily with human rights and i make
no political uh distinctions
in fact it is because i make no
political distinctions and because i
come at it with an apolitical point of
view that the reason for my presence
here is so
uh apropos
it's been a long journey for me to
get to this room
really
it's the culmination of almost a half
century of human rights investigative
journalism going back to
i guess the 60s and 70s that's in the
20th century for those of you
tuning in
and
i've looked into the case of the
armenians i've looked into the case of
the appalachians looked into the
african-americans and jim crow
the
native americans the
muslims and the mesopotamians going all
the way back in history of course the
jews and holocaust because my jews are
holocaust survivors
and
i specialize
in one thing
asking the question
that must be asked
that everyone is afraid to answer
i can give you the
the
parallel to when i wrote my book ibm in
the holocaust
i saw
an ibm machine as the very first relic
at the holocaust museum here in
washington dc but six million people had
seen it before me
and no one sought to ask the question
what was ibm's role in the holocaust and
of course as we know ibm organized all
six phases of the holocaust the
identification of the jews their
expulsion from society their uh
confiscation of their assets
ghettoization deportation and even the
extermination and they've never denied
it
when i did my book on eugenics war
against the weak we talked about
genocide
by america
against 90 percent of its own citizens
by the greatest powers
in this country the intellectual elite
the progressive elite
fueled by corporate money and corporate
philanthropy
the carnegie institution and the
rockefeller foundation
which resulted in the sterilization of
some sixty thousand americans and the
untold erasure
of untold numbers of people who were
never born
and this is what got me into the realm
of philanthropic abuse
and i became studied
in the topic
of charities who take their money for a
non-charitable purpose and for tax money
which is being misused when i did my
work on eugenics
this program that i wrote about was not
a secret
it was law in 27 states
it been passed and developed by the
greatest political minds legislative
minds medical minds academic minds
judicial minds
but no one sought to ask the question
was this genocide and of course under
international law the destruction of
this many people was of course genocide
about 10 years ago
i was assigned by the jta that's the
jewish
news syndicate
to investigate the ford foundation
for
funding
numerous groups in the united states
in the u.n durbin
conference against racism
and these organizations were blatantly
anti-semitic anti-zionist anti-israel
anti-peace
and
when this investigation broke all over
the world some 20 members of congress
pressured the ford foundation
to
remove its funding from these groups and
that's exactly what the ford foundation
did
and they channeled their money into a
new organization name of that
organization was the new israel fund
now over the past
10 years
many people have come to me to ask me to
take a fresh look at how taxpayer money
is being used
in israel
we're spending a lot of money
in this country
to assist peace and reconciliation in
israel
because that is an american goal that is
an american value
but it turns out
that my investigation documents
that taxpayer money is actually
financing the flames of confrontation
and even terrorism
i'm going to be briefing today
on policy
on what is wrong with american policy
what is wrong with american legislation
and what we can do about it
i'm going to start with one of the most
astonishing
facts that i found
american taxpayer money
is
fungibly financing
terrorist salaries
of
palestinian terrorists
who are convicted and serving time in
israeli prison and the more heinous
their crime
the more of your money they're getting
here's how it works
if a
palestinian terrorist
commits
an act of terror against innocent
civilians
say
a family or a bus
with a bomb or even just uh killing
someone with a knife
that person immediately goes on an
palestinian authority salary
and that salary
escalates
under the
a law a palestinian law called the law
of the prisoner and the more heinous the
crime
the more money the palestinian gets
and these amounts to some of the best
salaries and the best compensation
in the palestinian authority
we're talking about
thousands
of dollars a year
and we're talking about thousands of
dollars each month now here's how it
works how do they decide what's the most
heinous crime
they let the israelis decide
it depends upon the prison sentence so
the sliding scale
involves
so much money for one year prison five
years of prison
10 years of prison and even 30 years of
prison
this money is paid directly to the
prisoner
during his time in prison it's a reward
for the act of terrorism
the prisoner is provided with a poa
that's a power of attorney and he
transmits that money for holding or
spending to his wife his girlfriend his
uh family his buddies his organization
in some cases it's the plo in some cases
it's another terror cell
and where is this money coming from
the pa is constantly in the red
and it draws this money
from donor countries such as the united
states
this constitutes approximately
four to seven million dollars a month
and about six percent of the entire
palestinian economy
and it's a prioritized amount of money
that means if they got a million dollars
in the bank
and they've got starving kids on the one
hand they'll pay the prisoner salaries
first
and they'll take care of the starving
kids later it's a priority they have
their own
ministry the palestinian
ministry of prisoners
devoted to overseeing and executing this
program and they have a
quasi-governmental organization called
the prisoners club that makes sure that
if anyone tries to allocate monies in a
way that will circumvent the obligation
to pay the prisoner
this or this
prisoners club will agitate within the
palestinian community
more than that
any attempts
to stop that money
will be shut down by the so-called arab
streets
this is not
a secret program
this is a proud program this is a
program that the palestinians consider
to be precious
not only do the individuals
get a
uh a stipend
for a uh for for an act of terrorism
that stipend is actually linked
to a rank in the palestinian authority
and if the crime is heinous enough they
make the guy equivalent to an honorary
deputy minister
so you can go from rags to riches
and
from
being a nobody to a famous person
in the palestinian authority
just by blowing up a bus
or
stabbing
an individual that happened when i was
there
this spring
i was told well there hasn't been a lot
of violence in the pal in this area for
uh quite a while not serious
and there was a medical clown
and this person spent all this time
to the best of his visibility
giving medical therapy clown therapy to
victims of terrorism and not only just
the israeli kids but palestinian kids
everyone who comes along
this man was just standing
at a bus stop
and a palestinian
planned
took a bus down
to the junction
had a knife in his bag
walked up to the man
and stabbed him
and he died and he spilled right out on
the street
and that man knew he would not be shot
on the spot
because he knew
that once he put his weapon down
the israeli police
would not shoot to kill
he knew that once he went to prison
or once he was sentenced or once he got
into the criminal justice program his
family would become revered
they would become heroes in fact they
did become celebrities
and most of all he knows
that he's not going to serve 10 15 20
years
he knows
that in the near future
he's going to be on the list
for another prisoner swap
whether that is the next galactic elite
or whether that is the
the person they were planning to kidnap
just days ago when they discovered a
major tunnel
in gaza that was big enough to drive a
mack truck through
or whether that involves the simple act
of we're not going to come back and talk
at the table unless we get 400 prisoners
released and these prisoners are not
auto thieves
and bank robbers
the law specifically defines this as
those who have committed uh
acts against the israeli presence
and in my book financing the flames i
had the official spokesman of the
ministry of prisoners
actually
reading from the law
and he went so far as to make a point of
it and say now remember this isn't for
ordinary criminals this is just for
those who have
committed acts against the israeli
presence
now
many people in congress are shocked
about it
everyone i've told is shocked about it
the only one who's not shocked about it
is the palestinian leadership because
they have shouted this program from the
rooftops as a badge of honor
and
most of the bureau chiefs of the western
media in jerusalem
the diplomatic
community our state department
and the foreign ministries across europe
they know about it
there are organizations that follow this
they make special reports
they'll have a video like me
talking about this issue there are tv
specials within the palestinian
community about the righteousness of
righteousness of this program
and the only one who doesn't know are
the members of congress
and
their constituents
who are giving them the money
to transmit
fungibly
to palestinian terrorists as salary
that violates american law every nickel
because the law says we cannot pass any
money which would in any way
reach or benefit a terrorist and in this
case about six percent of it does and
when
palestinian authorities have been
confronted with this prospect that they
will be
forced or pressured
to stop funding this program
they say our prisoners are too precious
we will never stop
and have a term for it
the term is donor filth
i think the translation is something
different in arabic
but it's donor filth
and that means that any donor
who gives is any money and who says i
want it used for peaceful purposes
that money is considered tainted and
filthy because the greatest priority for
this money according to the words that i
have cited
is to benefit and compensate the
terrorists for a specific acts of
terrorism so your first question is how
come you're hearing about this today for
the first time
your second question is why hasn't your
congressman heard about this before this
video cast
and your third question is how come i
didn't read about this in the paper
yesterday
actually it's been in the times of
israel a couple of times
it's been in the new york times a couple
years ago
it's a fleeting reference the only thing
that was not done is it was not followed
up it was not investigated the sliding
scale was not there the names were not
provided the numbers were not provided
and that has been done in irrefutable
documentation in financing the flames so
now what are we talking about with
policy
a
we must immediately
stop funding
terrorist
salaries of convicted terrorists
serving in israeli prisons immediately
i should
note
that during the government shutdown the
recent government shutdown which this
may be
showing uh in a recorded version later
but it was just some days ago from the
time that i'm speaking now during that
government shutdown our government
employee
employees were not getting paid a salary
but the palestinian terrorists
were getting their salary
while american citizens trying to
achieve peace with their precious
dollars
didn't have a paycheck to buy groceries
at the end of the week
the second
issue
is clawback
once we have identified the fact that
millions of dollars
have illegally gone to the palestinian
authority
and that were given under false
pretenses
and or the assumption that they were not
they were going to comply with the law
that they would not benefit terrorists
now we have to say
we got that money back
you knew what the law was
it was not supposed to benefit
terrorists
you proudly told us there would be no
way that you would redline this money
its money is fungible you follow the
money i followed the money and i
followed it directly to where it is now
living in the pockets of terrorist
prisoners to the tune of about six
percent of what we pay through foreign
aid uh usaid um
special programs
etc
that's not going to be an easy process
because united states policy is a giant
carrier group it's very hard to turn
around but it's something that needs to
be done
now we're going to move on
let's move on to the subject to 501 c 3s
that's tax deductible organizations
another
area that i've devoted much work to
501 c 3s
are
charitable organizations
they're supposed to be engaged in
charitable acts
but as it turns out in the same way that
the ford foundation was using its tax
exempt status and there were many when i
did my funding hate piece for the jta
who challenged whether that tax exempt
status should continue
many which is probably one of the
reasons why the ford foundation
pulled out
of the durbin groups
and i'll be saying more about the ford
foundation soon
but
if it's a charitable organization they
should be involved in charitable acts
what people have told me what the
critics in israel have told me
and which was my duty to validate or
invalidate and i did validate it
was
that
the largest
of the operating charities
in israel today is the new israel fund
which
comes back to the same organization
that got the benefit of the ford
foundation money
when i did my original investigation
in 2003
funding hate
ford found foundation gave money into an
organization
alleged organization called the fort
israel fund
and the fort israel fund
then was intended to disperse and fund
money to other groups and if you check
many of the financial reporting papers
of the organizations get get the money
of the ford israel fund they will list
the fort israel fund as their funders
they will list the board of directors as
their funders they will list all sorts
of programs is being funded by the fort
israel fund
no such thing ford israel fund doesn't
exist
never existed
doesn't have an address
doesn't have a phone number
doesn't have a bank account
it's run out of some guy's house in new
jersey
who is an outside contractor actually a
very nice guy
and it's really just an identification
for a pool of money
that actually went to the new israel
fund
all right so now we know there's no new
israel
no
ford israel fund and there's more to the
story by the way
the ford foundation
saw the light
and not only pulled its money out of the
durbin groups it has now pulled its
money out of the out of the new israel
fund
and it has pulled its money
out of
it has pulled the right to use its name
in the fort israel fund the fort israel
fund
some
months ago had a makeover over is now
known as the social justice fund and
that's because this non-existent charity
making non-existent grants
through an entity that never existed
now has a new name
and that new name no longer reflects the
ford foundation
now this is a good time for me to say
something about the ford foundation they
cooperated with me
in all parts of my investigation
and
they have had a complete turnaround
in their outlook probably to new
leadership from their president louis
ubinus
they have funded
they're no longer funding agitation
groups they're now funding such things
as
the anti-defamation league which
promotes peaceful solutions they're
funding yad vashem which is the
holocaust memorial in israel and they're
trying to do the charitable activities
that their charter called for them to do
and by the way
just one bit of clarification
at for decades there's been no
connection between henry ford and the
ford motor company the great
anti-semites and hit and and hitler
colleagues and the ford foundation the
hitler family the ford family
exited the ford foundation some decades
ago and they're not connected to it so
the ford foundation now is almost a
detached second iteration of its
original henry ford um
identity
so
i just want to make clear that the ford
foundation cooperated with me and i also
want to make clear that although i do
give
i am
did give some time investigating uh the
george soros
foundations and the new israel found the
new israel fund
was
very very helpful in all of my work and
very transparent with me and
hid just about nothing which is why i
was able to get just about everything
so
let's talk about what the new israel
fund is doing
the new israel fund is getting
charitable donations
but it's not a charity
the new israel fund is a social action
entity
it's a political entity
they like to say
we're not about soup kitchens we're
about social change
and
they fund
about 800
other ngos that's non-governmental
organizations in israel
and many of those organizations are
doing very important work they're
uplifting impoverished families they're
assisting battered women
they're looking for ethnic equality in a
country that
so many ethnic fab fabrics are coming
together to pull at the cloth
so there's a lot that they are doing
that is very good and that's important
to recognize that the people who i have
investigated are trying hard to achieve
their goals but just as the people
running the eugenics program in the
united states thought that the best way
to achieve greatness in america utopia
in america was to erase the existence
of 90 percent
of our american citizenry
members of knesset that the israeli uh
legislature and members of the american
of the israeli military
have come together
in a multitude
to tell me that they believe
that the new israel fund
is committed to
destabilizing the israel defense forces
and erasing the jewish identity
from the state of israel
itself
i'll be specific
i'll give you just three names but there
are many more
the deputy knesset the deputy speaker of
the knesset and that would be
yoni chet boon
went on record
stating
that the new israel fund
is determined to destabilize the idf i'm
going to tell
why he thinks that soon
uh mk lewin
uh
agreed with that completely
mk fondue kirschenbaum also agreed with
that they went on the record and they
added their
viewers legislatures as legislators
that the new israel fund was working
through its many funded organizations
to erase the identity of the jewish
state
using taxpayer money american and other
taxpayer money
and furthermore
to
create a political force in knesset
a political party a political wing a
political movement
using american taxpayer money
as a war chest
now let me just tell you something
um
there's a lot of politics
in israel
and naomi pace
uh
the communications director of the new
israel fund uh once said to me actually
several times everything in israel is
political
politics is okay in israel that's all
they do is politics they can i mean if
you think there's a lot of politics in
the united states you can quadruple that
in israel
but amer every man woman and child
taxpayer
in the united states
should not pay
for the war chest
of a political party
in israel
and what do i mean by that
i mean that for every one million
dollars
in text don't in tax donations
that the new israel fund and any other
fund gets
four hundred and forty thousand dollars
has been subsidized by american
taxpayers
they like to say as i said we're not
about soup kitchens we're about social
change but the fact of the matter is of
the 800 plus organizations that they
fund
in israel
and of the many organizations that those
organizations fund
as this octopus goes down to smaller and
smaller uh arms
it's only scores of organizations
that are involved in the topic
that i'm currently talking about
today we shouldn't overlook
what's good
what's terribly good with what's
terribly bad involving the new israel
front that's the way to have bad policy
now
a couple of organizations were
spotlighted
by
the israeli military men
and i spoke to men at the bottom rank in
the middle rank at the top rank men in
the field i spoke to an organization
called consensus
which represents 300 officers
in the israeli military probably spread
across all of the services
and they spoke decisively and they
believe that the new israel fund through
several of its key
funding
recipients
is working to destabilize
the israeli military now why is that
important
because israel has proved
that it can't be beat
on the battlefield
with tanks artillery pieces and
airplanes
so they say that a new front
has a and they've all used this word a
new front has been opened up
in israel
and it's a human rights front
it's human rights
engaged
in political militancy
two organizations spring to mind
one is
an organization called betsellum
now what does betselem do
betsellum is interested
in recording infractions
uh
by israeli military men in the field
and how do they do this
when an israeli soldier
has been deployed
in the west bank or anywhere in israel
for that matter
he is surrounded
by protesters and activists with
handheld cameras sometimes just inches
from his face
he's
standing there and surrounded as you saw
in some of the pictures that i showed
you before and as you saw in the trailer
done for the book
while that's happening
the israeli
the palestinian with and left-wing
israeli protesters
are taunting the soldiers
they're insulting his mother
they're insulting his country they're
insulting his manhood they're insulting
his humanity they're taking flags in
hitting his face mask
the parents
are engaged in classic child
endangerment
classic human shield action they take
their own kids and they push their kids
right into a guy's m16
when finally
cameras rolling
if and should
the soldier react
that is videotaped
and that is sent up to the internet and
is the basis for a boycott action
or a prosecution
or a complaint
or the portrayal
of israeli military men
as brutes and bullies
even though they are probably the only
military in the middle east and one of
the few in the world that i can tell
tell you
about where every soldier carries his
vest in his shirt pocket a small card
reminding him of what his honor and duty
is to civilians
they take it seriously
and israel has a civilian army
and every high school kid does his time
for a couple of years when he gets out
of uh high school and uh and before he
goes to college
but there is no wiggle room for human
rights in the israeli
army is it possible for israeli military
transgressions throughout history
and
i've written a few books of history
about 10.
going back to the first professional
military men that is the first salaried
military men in history will be the
roman centurions and the roman
army there have always been infractions
that's always going to be the case
that's why we have human rights
to make sure
that there is a law in a standard but
human rights must never be political
human rights must never
draw a sharp line at one man's religion
everybody is entitled to the same
level of human rights and even soldiers
have human rights
that's called for many of the geneva
treaties
so
we have a situation where people are
playing for the camera now i record one
situation in in in the book
in a town called nava called nabi sella
is a small town it's it's a hamlet it's
residents numbers from
550 to
maybe 580 persons
they're all related uh through uh direct
or indirect family links they're all
part of one family
and
these individuals have a staged riot
every friday
it's not a spontaneous protest
it's a staged orchestrated planned
protest
everybody knows what to do
they are they march down the hill
and they try to get to the road to close
the road
the road is several meters down the hill
remember this
all media all legislators
all observers of the middle east and of
the israel-palestinian
conflict
we're not talking about miles here
we're talking about meters
it is sometimes
the distance involved
is oftentimes
shorter than from this wall to the edge
of the building
the protesters come down
the parents
shoved the kids into the uh soldiers
because the soldiers let them protest
they protest all through town but when
they approach the road the road must be
to the capital of israel and its other
cities must be kept open
the kids are pushed
the soldiers are prepped and trained
i've been in their sessions i had
bulletproof vests i had a kevlar helmet
i was ready for the ride for for the
tear gas and and uh the molotov
cocktails
and
when if and when the soldiers react
betselam and its volunteers who are
actually
members of the protest
will be there to capture the footage
now this is interesting
the volunteers for betselem
are actually the protesters themselves
or the cousin of the protester or living
in the household of the protester
or the next door neighbor of the
protester
and
these cameras are coming
from money
which has been provided by the new
israel fund
and by other organizations similarly
situated
who are who feel it's their goal
to have this situation play out and it
does play out
it plays out
every friday at approximately 1 p.m as a
journalist i was told exactly what time
to leave my hotel exactly what time to
arrive exactly what time the ride would
start and exactly what time uh
things would get hot
they played to the camera and in this
case it was my photographer
my photographer
was stuck in a traffic jam
my photographer
didn't leave his hotel in time or didn't
leave his home in time he was stuck
i got all these people
ready to riot
i got the soldiers standing with their
face masks and their guns
nothing's happening
why
no photographer
so there's a videotape on the internet
right now of me
with the protesters complaining that
there's been no act of violence by the
soldiers
against their protest
and that's a fraud and the fraud is
being perpetrated because i am there to
watch it and they're actually
complaining this will be the first time
in the history of the non-violent
movement that people have bitterly
complained that their protest was not
hit by soldiers
and then
my photographer his name was boaz
he finally got with the program
and he showed up
i said it's all over
you're late he said i did the best i
could
as soon as he's there
with the big-bodied wide angle lens
and the uh
mechanized camera bodies and the rolex
and all the and the lights and all this
kind of stuff they see him
the riot starts
rocks get thrown
crowd control measures go into effect
the scene is made
made for people are playing for the
camera if those cameras were not there
the action would not take place
and what does that mean
that means there could be one friday at
that town
without a riot wouldn't that be a start
just a tiny little start
beyond that
one of the chief organizers of the
protest
gets paid gets compensated
to record the details
but only when there's an act of violence
with injured parties
that means if it's a peaceful protest
and no one gets injured
there's no money
but if the protest gets out of hand
and causes
injuries
counter measures
afflictions
this person gets eighty five dollars
eighty five dollars is approximately
four times three to four times the
average daily wage in the palestinian
authority so one of the best paying jobs
in the palestinian authority
is to report on the casualties and
injuries that may result from a riot
that you yourself are part of
orchestrating
that is enabled by american taxpayer
policy
okay
now how am i sure
that they're playing for the camera
they're palestinians
in a tiny
town with only one street
and they speak arabic
the israeli soldiers
are teenagers
mainly just out of school
and they speak hebrew
but the entire riot is conducted in
english
it's conducted for the press
it's conducted for the eu it's conducted
for the observers and it's enabled by
taxpayer money
voted right here in this
in this building where i am standing
or across the corridors
by by people of their offices here
and other donor countries throughout the
e the the the the eu and the reason
i say it is american taxpayer policy
is because it is a taxpayer policy that
allows
non-charitable activities political
activities confrontation activities
to be funded
for
tax exempt organizations to the tune of
440 000
for every million dollars i think the
last time i checked in the last several
years the new israel fund was able to
garner
from all sources everywhere about a
quarter of a million dollars that's 250
billion dollars where does this money
come from it doesn't come from a special
allocation
from um the state of new mexico it
doesn't come from a special allocation
from the house of representatives it
comes from individual donors
there are donors
many of them jewish
many of them who just don't know where
the money is going
or don't care
or do know
who are giving this money
to organizations not just to new israel
funds but to many other funds
which are involved
in agitation and confrontation
activities you want to see the names of
these
organizations
go to their websites
hit the word donate
they tell you which tax-exempt entity
will accept pass-through funds the money
is washed for them through these
entities some of these entities don't
even have addresses some of these
entities are working out of po boxes and
somehow they're charities they say well
we're modern we don't need it in office
and i'll be happy to provide the
specifics by pointing them out in
chapter and verse
in financing the flames or through
the hearings
that i am calling for to take place as
soon as possible
on exactly what has happened with the
max
american taxpayer policy
this will also bring up several other
dynamics if we're to
write the course if we're to do things
correctly
and that is going to be
how do we address
the continued 501c3 status of
organizations not engaged
in charitable works but who which is the
spirit of the law but who are engaged in
political activity
and confrontation activity
what do we do to rectify the situation
and
help it going forward forward now i
didn't mean to just zero in on on with
betsel
and i want to emphasize that but someone
was very helpful and transparent to me
in all of my time in is in israel
there's another
organization called adala
and adala
is devoted to getting
israelis prosecuted as war criminals
in international tribunals
israel is surrounded
in a sea of war crimes
they're surrounded at the north by syria
where
i had to revise i spent six months
writing my book i had to revise the
death toll three times and the refugee
toll three times because there are so
many millions of refugees and and such a
high six digit number of um
of mass of massacred uh the deaths in
every family
uh lebanon where
there are sectarian bombings
to the north
to
israel's south and to israel's west
individuals can be
splashed with acid because they uh
they have not followed um certain types
of law um there is
people have political differences in
gaza
in egypt they throw them off rooftops
they don't even have kangaroo courts
they just see them they convict them by
virtue of an eye
of a visual decision and they throw them
off rooftops
but these organizations are dedicated
to
convicting israelis so israelis feel
they cannot make the right decision in
the field because no matter what they do
they're going to be second guessed and
triple guests
possibly in a court of law
possibly in an international war crime
tribunal now i also found fascinating
when i followed the money of these
organizations
that while there are jewish donors
giving money to the new israel fund
to give to betselman a dollar
for some reason these organizations i
don't want to zero in on them alone
there are many others
are
these organizations are also getting
abundant financing from funds banks and
other institutions which are controlled
by iran saudi arabia and iraq so what is
the common intersection
between iranian and saudi funding
and the funding that comes out of
greater new york city
and boston and all over and all over the
world
so this brings up the issue of uh
how do we close the loopholes you know
closing the loopholes is something we do
in this country god knows there's enough
loopholes to
drive a mac truck through
and
the first thing we do is we call into
question how the money is being spent
we found out that the internal revenue
service in this country
knows the concept of political action
and they
take lots of steps when they want to
so now it is time for the
irs
and the legislatures to determine
if the 501 c
c 3 status of these organizations is
justified
or part of it
may not be justified
because there's so much good work that
the new israel fund is doing that it is
just this monumental wing that has to be
addressed
and then of course we have to
look at
the donors
if the donors know
that their money is
circumventing the spirit of the law
if the donors are doing this
deliberately
naturally there would be prosecution
and claw back and penalties i believe
that most of the donors
are not aware of what is going on
and that means that the phrase
did know or should have known
comes into play that's the phrase that
they give to us
and then we will have to ask
were you aware that your money was
funding this
did you do your due diligence
is there amnesty
a question of amnesty should be uh
extended
or
a better way to say it
draw a bright line in the road as of
today
we now know that there are questions
it is possible
that donors
with the best feeling in their hearts
have given to
a cause
and not just the new israel fund but
many others that is spending their
moneys in ways
that they might not think correct
that they might not want to happen and
here's the interesting part
the new israel fund is doing nothing
beneath the table
the new israel fund is doing nothing
sabrosa they're completely transparent
you don't need an investigative reporter
named edwin black to figure this stuff
out
you just need a laptop and a mouse
and a google account
and you can go up there and you can see
all the activities that are being done
they are completely transparent all the
monies that are being spent
and you would do the same due diligence
that you would do in an organization
that you were investing in because
that's what a donation is an investment
are we going to invest in peace are we
going to invest in confrontation and the
answer is we need to invest in peace
because while i was in israel i found
that the same nation of israel that is
under attack
70 000 palestinians each day that 70 000
are going into israel israel across this
line
and working for israeli wages
equal wage
equal work conditions
equal employment
lots of watchdogs to make sure it
happens but these people
are hiding in the shadows
they don't have videographers
following them around
we have pictures of them
in the book
with their faces blocked out
and their facial characteristics change
because we don't want to get them killed
what's their death sentence
living and working in peace with
israelis with their name
with their neighbors
and that's why
the administration
is actually pushing
this program this approach of economic
uh cooperation
and peaceful co-existence
secretary kerry has a 4 billion dollar
investment plan why not
the two richest billionaires in the area
one palestinian and one israeli are both
offering to prepare their
to propel their their billions
into joint economic uh projects that
will uplift the entire land i had a guy
i spoke to in in gaza
and i went all over the west bank i sat
in the homes of the palestinian
protesters i listened to their point of
view i listened to the fathers of
israeli soldiers who had been killed by
terror terrorists i listened to the
human rights organizations
i listened to the knesset members i
listened to as many people as i could
find naturally
even though my work is not the seven
thousand words that would fill a series
in a newspaper it's 77 000 words
and even that leaves 99 percent of
everything out which is one of the
things i'm i say about all of my work
no matter how fat the book you're always
leaving out 99 of everything
my question is
is it not possible
for these people to live in peace
the same question has been asked
for decades and centuries as you know i
come at this from a historical
perspective i've written six books on
the ottoman empire and the uh and the
and middle east history going back all
the way to abraham
and i can tell you that the same program
was advanced in 1918
in
1920 at the san remo conference by the
league of nations where the israel
mandate was put into effect the
palestinian man the palestine mandate
was put into effect to create equal
homelands for arabs and jews and the
arabs declined and i can tell you that
the same thing occurred in 1936 and 37
with the peel commission when the
british said let us make if these people
cannot live together let us divide this
tiny tiny tiny land into two
halves and let these people live side by
side in peace to
two
nations for two peoples and that was not
accepted in 1948 there was a war of
independence when everyone when the
british withdrew and everyone was
invited to
declare their own state the israelis
declared their state the arabs did not
declare their state the um
uh the egyptians occupied gaza the
jordanians occupied the the west bank
and um
and the ceasefire said no lines shall be
drawn
we stopped shooting
but we're still not drawing lines
and this is going on war after war
treaty after treaty where nobody wants
to draw the lines now we have a chance
to draw the lines now there's another
round of talking but that will never
occur
as long as terrorists
are being paid
by american taxpayer funds fungibly
to commit acts of terror
and as long as our 501c3 donations
are paying for confrontation
and an erasure of the identity of the
jews you know one of the things i found
the jews in israel one of the things i
found fascinating
was that
we allow by this system
organizations who enforce
an anti-semitic regime
and perspective against jews in israel
let me give you an example of what i
mean by that
if a jew
goes to the temple mount
and his lip is seen to quiver
like that
he can be arrested or expelled
for a perceived prayer
an arab would not be
if a jew moves into a certain household
or plants an olive tree in a certain
area he will be confronted by one of the
funded ngos in israel
not because he didn't plant the olive
tree correctly not because he couldn't
afford to buy the house
but because he was jewish our open
housing laws would never permit in the
united states a person to be excluded
on the basis of their religion
and therefore
one of the things congress must do is
they must immediately monitor the
organizations
in question to make sure that none of
their funds either support acts of
terror acts of
acts of violence
[Music]
acts of breach of the peace
and indeed acts which discriminate
against any organization or any
individual
or any family because of their religious
background i remember sitting with um
adalah their representative another very
nice guy you know when you do these
investigations you find nothing but
devoted intellectual people involved in
this process we were sitting in the the
american colony hotel which is a great
hotel in east jerusalem
where lawrence of arabia spent some time
in general allenby and i asked him what
their mission was and said their mission
was to document
military war crimes and things of that
nature and they said whenever israel
retaliates against gaza
they document that and they send that
over for prosecution
i said what happens when gaza
shoots rockets over to israel
that's not our job
now i know the
adl the anti-defamation league in the
united states and they stand up for the
rights of gays and blacks and muslims
and jews and christians everywhere in
the world i know the naacp stands mainly
for its minority but does not stand
quiet when other people are afflicted in
its myths i know that many
equal rights in human rights groups in
this country would never consider
saying well we will recognize the human
rights of everyone except a jew yet this
is what our american policy this is what
congressional policy has manufactured
this incredible monster
that needs to be tamed this incredible
monster that needs to be undone and that
is the purpose for my coming here today
to congress to tell you that the
research i did in financing the flames
puts it all together
it puts it in one place
it uses intense tools of documentation
with hundreds of footnotes
with a 10 or 20 man documentation team
volunteers all over the world as i have
for all of my books helping me document
the process
there are more
pages in this book dedicated to
complementing
the good works of the nif for balance
that exist anywhere
in journalism
but it's all going to start over again
now
today we start a fresh day
today congress says
we've made a mistake
we have built a bridge
and it's not a bridge of peace
it's like the bridge over the river kwai
abraham lincoln
said who has done it
to us
we have done it to ourselves
and that is why i've come to congress
that is why i've given six months of my
life to writing financing the flames
and now
i'll yield to the rest of the world and
i'll take questions
thank you very much
i'm going to take some questions
both from the assembled media here we
have several and i'm going to take some
questions from people constituents all
over the united states
who have sent their questions in
um
in a
so i'm going to start
by asking
here's a question from florida
all right let me take that one second
let me start with uh shirley dave uh do
you have a question on behalf of the
armstrong williams show
uh you answered my question i just want
you asked
you asked early on if this will ever end
and that's my question do you think this
will ever end how do you think you're
going to reach
congress you know to stop the terrorists
from
being funded by america
congress is the house of congress is a
house divided i understand that
but the house of congress although it is
divided is unified on several issues
they're unified on the issue of mideast
peace they're unified on the issue of
reconciliation between palestinian and
arab they're unified on the issue of of
charitable works and they're unified on
the issue of terrorism
i believe
that we can start today
and we can do the job
that the rest of of
of the media and the world has not done
and bring this to the attention of
congress i'm asking for hearings i know
that uh the armstrong williams show will
be asking for those hearings too and i'm
thinking it's possible we can make some
prog we can make some progress
let me take a question from
you have a question
i would just say uh
you know there's a lot of you know
separation between the parties do you
think that there is
a way
um
to get to the world more than you know
just the united states in the matter
how you know because to find these
agreements it do you believe it could be
more than just drawing lines
uh which agreements so you talked about
how um
you know they're not drawing lines in
these agreements and it's creating
separation do you think there is you
mean the warring parties in the middle
east yes
what the warring parties in the middle
east do is got nothing to do with this
session has nothing to do with this
question
the question is will they be allowed to
decide on their own
without that um without that conflict
without that discussion without that
disagreement
confounded and
and confused
by taxpayer money which is being spent
to achieve the exact opposite actually
as a bargaining chip
so really
if there would be success here
the parties would be left alone to talk
amongst themselves but peace doesn't
have a chance because peace doesn't pay
in israel because there's no money in it
only confrontation pays only terrorism
pays it's kind of like asking saudi
arabia to stop exporting oil that's what
they do for a living
in the palestinian authority this donor
money comes when the street gets hot
people don't pay extra because somebody
worked in a hotel and was courteous
people don't pay extra because some
israelis and arabs got together and had
dinner
and said how do we work it out i want my
line to be there and you want my line to
be there what can we do in the middle
the greatest territorial conflicts
in the world and for this work i studied
them i studied all the walls
in the world i think there were 41 walls
i studied the walls of northern ireland
i studied the ones up to today the wall
between yemen and saudi arabia i studied
the war the wall in cyprus the walls of
beirut the wall that we're building
between us and mexico i've studied all
of these walls
territorial disputes
they go back to abraham they're in the
bible
i'll be on my hill and you'll be on
on your hill people of good will
can make that decision
people of good will can say
there's 300 feet between my house and
your house
let's work it out
neighbors have always been able to come
together so really don't ask we can't
ask the wrong question
this is a human rights issue and human
rights must never be politicized and
under the mask of human rights we must
not mobilize millions for the sake of
confronting human rights and creating a
political imbalance
okay
all right i'm going to take a question
now
from
detroit
this is from martin
and martin wants to know
martin wants to know if
just as hamas and hezbollah are have
massive charitable operations
but do not get american taxpayer money
should the new israel fund be put in the
same box well i'm sorry to say that's a
a
a totally wrong question to ask
you should never mention the new israel
fund and hamas and hezbollah
in the same breath
the reason i understand the reasoning
behind this wrong question
hezbollah and
hamas all have charitable wings
where they have soup kitchens and
summer camps and things of that nature
but they also have this militant wing
now the new israel fund does have its
massive charitable wing and it has a
massive political wing but there's
nothing approaching the scope of
hezbollah and hamas in this arrangement
but
the way you avoid it going into that
is by setting bright lines of what can
and cannot be done
with american taxpayer money remember
anyone can start a political party
in israel
all they need is a photocopier and they
got a political party the question is
should every man woman and child
in iowa florida and north carolina
pony up for the war chest for that
organization to have a political party
let me take another question
all right
this is a question from a publication
called the oliga miner
the alga miner is one of our publication
sponsors
stand by and um
one of the questions that they asked if
i found it
here it is
is um
by the way the alga miner i'm reminded
to say the chairman is elie wiesel
they're one of the official co-sponsors
of my
project
and
they're i did not know that ellie wiesel
was a journalist
in his earlier days
as i was
in stillham but uh so the question from
the managing
editor there
is
how come so few people understood what
was going on with the new israel fund
and um
we have interviewed several nif donors
and not one of them knew about these
activities
the new israel fund
once again which does many good things
and has this
this agitation wing
as part of its philosophy
the new israel fund is completely
transparent and if donors
are so naive is to give their hundreds
of thousands or millions of dollars to
organizations where they have not done
their due diligence to see what is going
on then i guess it's sort of follows the
model of all of wall street where people
are given money in organize to
corporations and investing and then the
corporations go belly up but in this
particular case
uh the uh
the um
the organization the in individuals and
the foundations are investing in peace
but the peace dividend is not coming i
think the main reason the donors don't
know
is because the media is the spotlight
in this country
and people must be informed and while
there's a vibrant
business press that covers every title
and jot of what is going on in the
business world
there are very few people like myself
who investigate what's going on in the
human rights world that's what i did
with carnegie that's why i did with
rockefeller that's what i did with the
ford foundation and i've done it now not
despite like the spotlight the new
israel fund but with about 80
organizations that i looked at i looked
at all their financial records and
i think it's the start of a new day
i'll take one more question
all right this is similar to the same
question i got wednesday
the um
the new israel fund is uh famous for
retaliation are you uh fearing the new
israel fund what have they done
new israel fund is famous for
retaliation that's true a lot of people
were afraid to speak to me uh on the
record many people did
lots of famous people said lots of
government officials said i'd rather not
mention any company by name but any
organization by name but
we're um
we all know who we're talking about so i
asked that very question to the head of
the nif his name is daniel sokatch
and i quote from his response
he says
um and daniel soch is the number one guy
in uh
in san francisco it's funny quote this
is clear to me it's a symptom of where
we are
the nif does not go after anyone like
that
i do not i do think some of these folks
are saying that the nif is now
synonymous
with the boogeyman
but it bears very little relation to
reality if we had the power that so many
on the left and right attribute to us i
ask why are we struggling against so
many attacks we get blamed for
everything
it's patently absurd it bears no
relation to reality it would be
laughable if it wasn't sort of sad
so in other words
the new israel fund
has been spotlighted before by many
critics
perhaps not in the united states but
certainly in israel and that just shows
as soon as they say which they say all
the time it's a bunch of right-wing guys
that's to prove positive that it's
political
because if how does a charity
become the object of a right-wing or a
left-wing attack unless they're involved
in politics if you're involved in
politics you're certainly not a
charitable or organization as to what
has happened to me
um i know that a lot of things have
happened to me
uh since i started this investigation i
know that um uh
members of the ngo community that i
investigated and named
um
went to my editors
weeks before i went to my editors and
said we know edwin black is writing an
article for you we were approached by
individuals
who
for press conferences you were one of
them a couple of days ago who
said they'd heard about it and they just
wanted to see what it was
and get a copy we checked them out they
had nothing to do with with the media
they suddenly appeared they said they
got an invitation when they didn't we
know that the individuals have contacted
certain people we know that there was an
emergency meeting of tax attorneys in
washington d.c
in mid-october
actually laid out mid to late october
and that emergency meeting of tax
attorneys was designed
to
answer anything that congress might
throw at it
and so
while many people
uh talk about retaliation of the nif
uh after you've done ibm
ford
general motors carnegie and rockefeller
uh the new israel fund
is not a real problem
so if there are any other questions
from any of the policy people in the
room any of the congress you you have a
question i want to ask you a question
what is your first name kyle kyle yes
kyle i wanted to ask you um
you said that uh this issue of paying
salaries for palestinian prisoners was
no surprise to
you know the ambassadors and the policy
people and the foreign ministers uh yet
somehow is a surprise to members of
congress one of the first things that
any congressman is going to do if they
want to hold hearings is ask the state
department what do you know about this
and it leads to the question
are they are they misinforming congress
do you think and if so why
well first of all they haven't been
asked the right questions so they
haven't misinformed congress
but there is such a thing as omissive
misrepresentation
and if you knew that there was a
terrorist
getting your money you would be duty
bound
to report it
and our country our administration
should not be
vibrantly and robustly
allowing american taxpayer money to be
fungibly
financed into terrorist salaries we
should just abruptly say this has got to
stop now let me let me give you a simile
the biggest demonstration in the history
of mankind
occurred in
egypt some months ago
the biggest petition in the history of
mankind occurred in egypt some months
ago the muslim brotherhood was dethroned
the question wasn't i have my own tv
show i asked this question everybody in
the media was asking this question was
it a military coup
and if so does that not disqualify it
for
u.s funding
and of course
those of us who know the history of
democrat of democratic movements
uh those of us who know uh that uh
people like adolf hitler were
brought to power through the electoral
process
those of us who know that elections
don't make democracies democracies make
elections
though
those of us who know that democracy can
be hijacked by the wrong people
who openly admit they're hijacking it
for reasons that are non-democratic when
there was a correction
and these people were put out and now
there's a genuine
interfaith democratic movement in
in egypt where the coptic
uh patriarch
is actually on the dais
with the muslim leaders that's a real
turning point
so
immediately congress said oh
let's discuss it let's debate it is it
is it not it immediately went to the
front page
so congress can if at once
stop dead in its tracks
and say
what have we done
and they need to do that here they need
to not take a long time doing it
because every day
that congress delays in its hearing
every day that congress delays every day
that congress delays
in rectifying its wrong in this
area leaves open the possibility that
some
bright-eyed
palestinian villager
living in poverty
like the one who killed that medical
clown
will feel this is my chance
for money this is my chance and by the
way
i just want to add an addendum here one
of the most astonishing things i found
in this research
was that organizations
who claim were just here for democracy
have no problem undermining the
democracy
in israel i referred now and you saw it
in the trailer to the new israel fund
which is committed to democratic
processes
which brags about the fact
that it can convince or cajole knesset
members not to vote in their own knesset
in their own legislature
interrupting elections interrupting free
vote
is not an act of democracy
so
i think
we need to
define what is wrong with the system
take a good hard look at the system
admit that there's a new entity that
never existed before
just as there was a king coal and a king
oil
and a king corn and now we've become
aware of big data
we have big ngo
and big ngo
reports to no one
big ngo
belongs to no one they're international
the new israel fund can not only pick up
its money in washington dc they have a
whole office in switzerland they can get
whatever they want through
through
swiss channels if they want
if they don't like the law they will
overturn the law
if they don't like what happened when
they tried to over
overturn the law they will go to the um
to the supreme courts
if they don't like the action of the
supreme courts they will appeal the
supreme court to the u.n
they say well that's what we do in a
democratic process that's what the
people of the land do in a democratic
process
that's not what is done from boston
and san francisco
as we pull the strings on what is and is
not going to be done with the legitimacy
of israeli law a law by the way that
goes back to the beginning
of the of the judeo-christian ethic i
hope that answers your question is there
another question here do you have a
question
with that ladies and gentlemen thank you
very much for having me i hope to come
back to a hearing room
soon thank you